hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to another math video to
help you boost your score in your math
class improve your understanding and
hopefully make learning math a lot less
stressful so what we're going to talk
about in this video is how to use the
power rule when you're finding
derivatives so what is a power rule well
okay you can see the formula over here
this is the derivative when you have a
variable raised to a power okay and you
can see this is n times X to the N minus
1 what we do is we take this power we
bring it down in front of the base here
and we subtract 1 from the exponent so
it goes down by one degree so we're
going to take a look at some examples so
say we want to take the derivative of
this trinomial 3x squared plus 2x plus 1
you can see the powers here we have X to
the 2nd power X to the first power and
just a constant 1 so what we're going to
do is we're going to take this power
we're gonna bring it down in front of
the ok the base your ax there's a 3
there and this is what's called the
constant multiple rule but you're going
to multiply this times a 3 that's going
to be 6 X to the and you're going to
want to subtract 1 from the power so
that's going to become X to the 1st when
we take the derivative of 2 X okay you
don't see it but there's a 1 there when
we bring the one down in front 1 times 2
is 2 this is going to be X to the 1
minus 1 which is 0 okay but anything
that is e ro power just going to be 1 1
times 2 is 2 and then if we take the
derivative of a constant through a
constant is always going to be 0 again 0
is nothing we don't have to write that
so our derivative is just going to be 6x
plus 2 now remember what a derivative is
it's really a formula for the slope of
the tangent line to this graph or to
this curve along any point so here we
have a formula for finding that slope of
the tangent line to this graph let's
look at another example so this one here
we have five divided by x squared well
okay one of the important things in
calculus says you're starting to get
into this course further is that you'll
be rewriting and putting in different
forms to make it easier to work with so
what we can do is we can rewrite this as
5 times X to
negative 2 power because remember when
you bring this from one side of the
fraction bar to the other you change the
exponent sign to the opposite
okay so we've rewritten it so it fits
this power format okay and so now what
we're going to do we're going to take
the derivative so what we do is we take
that exponent we bring it down in front
of the variable in front of the base
there's a 5 there already so by the
constant multiple rule we're just going
to multiply by 5 that gives us negative
10x to the now you want to subtract one
sometimes students get a bit confused
here but you just want to subtract one
so it's actually going to make it a
larger number but it's a larger negative
number right and then we can finally we
can rewrite this as negative 10 divided
by X cubed so the negative exponent just
it's just affecting the base X here and
we're taking the reciprocal moving it
back to the denominator so you already
know that from some of your previous
classes but just wanted to remind you
about that and then this last one here
we have square root of x but again you
can rewrite this as X to the one-half
power remember the denominator that's
the root right and the numerator that's
the power so this is really like X to
the one-half power so now it fits our
power format and we can use the power
rule to take the derivative so what
we're going to do here is we're going to
take the one-half we're going to bring
it down in front of the X and then we're
going to subtract one so one half minus
one is actually negative one half now
again just like the last problem you
have that negative exponent you can take
the reciprocal so this is going to be
1/2 see the 2 is in the denominator
we're gonna bring this also down to the
denominator we're just taking the
reciprocal that's gonna be X to the
one-half power but remember the one-half
power is actually the square root so
this is 1/2 times square root of x now
you might be saying well don't I have to
rationalize that well for all purposes
right now we'll just leave it like this
so usually you're using this formula to
find the slope of the tangent line to
the curve so it's probably just easier
just to work with it just as it is here
but again so that's the power rule you
just take that exponent or that power
you bring it down in front and then you
subtract one from the exponent if it
happens to be something in front of the
the X here when you're bringing it
you would just multiply those two
quantities together so I hope this
helped you to understand how to use the
power rule better subscribe to the
channel check out some of my other
videos and I'll see you in the next
video